cloyes de l'alabama sera la plus
répressive des états unis sur
l'avortement mais c'est pas la plus
répressive dans le monde
sébastien en fait dans plusieurs pays
c'est totalement illégal vous pouvez le
constater sur cette carte céline donc
dans les pays envers ces permis sans
restriction alors que dans les pays en
rouge c'est généralement interdits voici
quelques exemples concrets
d'abord le salvador ici c'est sans doute
les temps le plus sévère au monde en la
matière en fait depuis une réforme de
l'avortement est criminel même dans les
cas de viol
même dans les cas où la vie de la mère
est en danger et en fait selon les juges
la perte d'un bébé est considérée comme
un homicide aggravé même parfois dans
des comptes fausse couche
c'est passible de 30 à 50 ans de prison
et ce sont des restrictions qui
n'appartiennent pas seulement à
l'hémisphère sud
voyez même en europe sur l'île de malte
une île très conservatrices très
catholique bien c'est l'un des derniers
pays d'europe encore où l'avortement est
illégal et là bas ça peut valoir jusqu'à
trois ans de prison
alors voilà pour les pays en rouge alors
que pour les pays en orange ou c'est une
interdiction partielle un exemple dont
vous souvenez sans doute l'argentine oui
en août dernier le sénat a rejeté donc
la légalisation de l'avortement donc
c'est toujours interdits à moins d'un
viol ou dans les cas où la santé de la
mère est compromise mais même avec des
lois très restrictive ya des pays qui
n'arrivent pas à éliminer l'avortement
loin de là en argentine justement selon
les évaluations du ministère de la santé
il ya chaque année plus de 350 1000
avortements clandestins est en fait
statistique éloquente dans le monde le
taux d'avortement dans les pays où
l'avortement est légal atteint 34
avortements par mille femmes alors que
dans les pays où c'est généralement
prohibé on pourrait s'attendre à ce que
ce soit plus bas mais ça augmente
légèrement me direz vous à 37 sur 1000
alors ce dont on se rend compte c'est
que ce soit légal ou non le taux
d'avortements reste le même
ce qui change ce sont les risques
qu'encourent les femmes qui
reçoivent une un avortement clandestin
voyez sur 56 millions d'avortements
chaque année près de la moitié sont à
risque et 8 millions sont pratiqués dans
des conditions dangereuses c'est à dire
pratiqué par du personnel incompétent
ça peut mener jusqu'à une
hospitalisation encore pire à la mort de
la mère des situations terribles merci
beaucoup c'est facile non plus